[Musique]
en
c'est une plateforme de mise en relation
entre parents qui sert à covoiturer ou
accompagner les enfants aux trajets
d'activités extrascolaires uniquement
entre parents selon les parents n'ont
pas forcément la disponibilité en terme
d'agenda 1 mardi à 17 heures mercredi
matin à 10 heures alors que d'autres
parents sont disponibles pour faire ce
trajet
[Musique]
on s'inscrit simplement sur le site qui
drive ou points comme on renseigne ses
trajets d'activité que ce soit un trajet
pour une mise en relation avec une
personne trois trajets cinq trajets égal
à cinq mises en relation avec ce qu'on
appelle les qui driver les parents
accompagnateurs
on prend le forfait qui est adapté à son
nombre de mises en relation et on n'a
plus qu'à définir toutes ces activités
il ya deux modèles en fait on quand on
s'inscrit et qu'on cherche un trajet on
peut aussi sans obligation mais on peut
devenir un qui drivers pour accompagner
aussi les enfants des autres et faire un
grand réseau de parents de confiance on
peut aussi être un qui driver bénévoles
évidemment il ya toute une sécurité qui
est mise en place pour l'accompagnement
des enfants
[Musique]